mais d'abord l'image forte de cette
journée le parlement français de goût
qui ovationnent volodymyr zelensky
femmes éric caire
dans son discours volodymyr zelensky a
d'abord parlé des civils visés par les
frappes russe dans son pays comme lors
du bombardement d'une maternité à
marioupol avant d'appeler les
parlementaires à observer une minute de
silence en hommage aux victimes
le président ukrainien a ensuite demandé
l'aide de la france
nous attendons de la france et de son
leadership qu'elle fasse en sorte que la
russie cherche la paix pour mettre fin à
cette guerre contre la liberté
une guerre dans laquelle l'ukraine
défend les valeurs de l'europe a rappelé
vladimir zelensky demandant aux
européens de poursuivre les livraisons
d'armes ainsi que de nouveaux paquets de
sanctions économiques contre l'agresseur
russe avant de critiquer des entreprises
françaises toujours présente en russie
les entreprises françaises doivent
quitter le marché russe rno auchan
leroy-merlin doivent cesser d'être les
sponsors de la machine de guerre de la
russie un discours qui contenait
plusieurs références à la france des
tranchées de verdun à belmondo en
passant par la devise liberté égalité
fraternité
jeudi le président ukrainien s'adressera
au parlement suédois
et on débat autour de cette journée un
chef de guerre face au parlement
français avec gayet ackermann bonsoir
bienvenue route vous retrouvez vous êtes
historienne spécialiste de la russie
post-soviétique hauteur du régiment
immortel la guerre sacrée de poutine
c'est aux éditions premier parallèle
christian cambon bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous étiez évidemment au sénat
cet après midi vous êtes sénateur l ère
du le de marne et président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées alain
guillemoles bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste à la croix spécialiste des
questions économiques et internationales
ancien correspondant à kiev où publier
une graine le réveil d'une nation c'est
aux éditions les petits matins j'ai
accueilli allemand laetitia khl pas il
est organiste politique bonsoir laetitia
gaillac avant de commencer avec vous
comment vous analysez la stratégie de
volodymyr zelensky qu'est ce qui vous a
marqué tout simplement dans son discours
cet après midi
ce qui m'a marqué c'est sa stratégie
générale parce que ce n'est pas le
premier parlement devant lequel il parle
et à chaque fois ils le trouvent des
analogies historiques
il trouve des choses qui est vraiment
accroche le coeur du peuple auquel il
s'adresse à travers ces parlementaires
et donc ça va être winston churchill
pour les britanniques et pour nous ça va
être bien sûr aussi bien la grande
révolution française les valeurs
françaises
que aussi les pages sombres de
l'histoire nationale avec les chants de
verdun la première guerre mondiale et
cédera donc c'est en communiquant
absolument extraordinaire qui qui
touche la corde sensible
dans tous les parlements où il passait
bien sûr le parlement français n'a pas
été une exception
il
hélas la standing ovation
l'ovationnent debout parce que ils
touchent ils touchent au coeur et il
faut dire que l'actualité que nous
livrons tous à travers les images
télévisées d horreur absolue bien sûr
dispose un autre réceptivité quant à son
message et on va parler évidemment cette
stratégie de l'opinion question comment
il s'adresse au parlement des grandes
démocraties européennes enfin il se pose
en défenseur des valeurs démocratiques
occidentales c'est aussi ça cette
stratégie depuis depuis plusieurs jours
aux appuis en semaine oui je crois que
cette
cette tournée des parlements si j'ose
dire dire ça quand cette tournée des
parlements et est lourde de sens d'une
part par la profondeur et l'émotion
qu'il met dans sa communication car au
tout début il a encore évoqué tous les
malheurs que son peuple subit toutes les
violences effroyables que son peuple
subit et je crois que venant de lui en
direct nous le recevons encore avec plus
d'intensité que les images que l'on peut
voir bien sûr par ailleurs s'adresser
ici en france à l'ensemble du parlement
assemblée nationale et sénat c'est un
événement rarissime d'avoir exactement
le même ordre du jour et puis vivre la
même séquence à la fois en s'adressant à
l'assemblée nationale c'est l'ensemble
des citoyens le sénat plutôt les
territoires les collectivités
je crois que tout ceci donne beaucoup de
beaucoup d'intensité beaucoup de
profondeur à son à son propos et je
pense que c'est censé aussi nous
mobiliser
d'abord pour bien comprendre
l'agression que ce peuple est en train
de vivre et puis je pense aussi nous
solliciter dans deux directions et nous
a proposé de direction d'une part
effectivement tout faire pour que la
france membre du conseil de sécurité un
interlocuteur important
agissent pour le cessez le feu pour que
ce drame épouvantable cette catastrophe
s'interrompt et puis il nous lance
défi pour plus tard pour qu'enfin
l'ukraine retrouve des conditions de vie
et de paix ce sera déjà une situation
effroyable mais je pense qu'il a évoqué
les accords de minsk qui sont
malheureusement morts est décédé mais il
attend aussi de la france un rôle plus
particulier nous concernant et je crois
que les parlementaires ont cette
responsabilité
pour le futur alain guillemoles
qu'est-ce qui vous avoue marqué dans un
discours si vous deviez vous faire
ressortir un passage vous diriez quoi
alors je enfin effectivement je trouve
qu'il a ici cible très bien sa
communication il est à chaque fois
qu'ils se retrouvent devant un parlement
enfin ils expriment des demandes très
particulière et donc ce qui m'a marqué
c'est aussi qu'à travers le parlement il
a adressé un message à un certain nombre
d'entreprises françaises au chant leroy
merlin
renault qui est qu'il a cités nommément
alors leroy merlin en particulier enfin
c'est un cas particulièrement dramatique
parce qu'il ya un magasin leroy merlin
qui a été bombardé en ukraine il ya deux
jours et donc le personnel de ces
magasins demande que
leroy merlin se retire de russie enfin
les personnels ukrainien et puis comme
leroy merlin est aussi présent en russie
va et que la maison mère elle pour
l'instant ne dit rien j'ai vu qu'à un
syndicaliste de cette entreprise demande
et enfin interpellé la direction du
groupe sur son silence enfin voilà et
c'est sûr que chaque entreprise
française se retrouve aujourd'hui devant
une un choix difficile 1 mais enfin
zemlinsky a eu quand même le sens
tactique on peut dire de mettre le doigt
sur des sujets qui nous concernent et
puis alors peut-être que ils suivent pas
ou en tout cas il a le pur sans doute
l'ambassadeur qui suit la campagne
française parce que je sais pas si vous
avez entendu ce matin sur rtl la
réaction du président de total enfin
total énergie patrick pouyanné qui avait
été mis en cause on va dire par yannick
jadot le candidat europe ecologie les
verts qui qui disait yannick jadot il
accusait total énergie de complicité de
crimes de guerre patrick pouyanné il y
avait vraiment de l'émotion dans sa
réaction l'écoutent messieurs jadot
accuse
les cent mille salariés total des
congrès sont
gravissimes c'est une insulte est-ce que
vous pensez que nous sommes pas des
êtres humains et que nous réussissons
pas tous les jours vous avez pas vous
avez ainsi là je vais chez la photo de
deux personnes ces deux soldats
ukrainiens ce sont deux employés de
total énergie ce sont les deux héros de
mon entreprise aujourd'hui et on nous
accuse de crimes mmc pas acceptable
monsieur jadot d'ailleurs au passage il
passe son temps à dire du mal de mon
entreprise que je veux faire c'est
qu'elle fait baisser dans les sondages
je ferais mieux de s'occuper du sort de
sa campagne et d'arrêter de nous
insulter c'est assez rare
d'entendre une telle émotion dans la
voix d'un patron d'un groupe
multinational très je pense que si on se
mettait à la place d'un conseiller en
communication on lui dirait de ne pas
faire ça c'est pas une bonne réponse si
vous voulez de répondre à ce qu'il dit
lui être des attaques du registre de
l'émotion ne faut pas répondre par
l'émotion il faut répondre on l'accuse
de quelque chose alors on attend surtout
auditeurs téléspectateurs français on
attendait fait on attendait mais
j'avais aussi aussi des réponses et des
fraises en larmes de crocodile pardon du
mot là dessus parce que dans la réponse
de ce qu'il fallait en totalité de
l'interview il a aussi répondu il a
montré un peu la quadrature du cercle
quel sens qu'en bon parce qu est-ce qui
est ce que total peut faire plus que les
états pour l'instant les états ont pas
soyons pas décidé d'un embargo sur le
gaz et pétrole russe est ce que c'est un
patron de deux groupes de le faire et
c'est toute la difficulté des
entreprises qui ont des contrats il ya
ce qu'on appelle la clause du grand père
c'est là que les contrats qui sont
antérieurs aux événements doivent être
exécutés et vous ne vous ne pouvez pas
brusquement
lorsque vous êtes à la tête d'une
entreprise de l'importance de total
coupez la pompe couper le robinet et
partir comme un comme un voleur et
saskatoon qui avait patrick pouyanné il
parce que ça gaze s'il interrompt sent
qu'il ya un embargo décidé par les états
il doit rembourser des sommes il va
enrichir encore mais l'armée de poutine
c'était son disque du temps d'autant que
et il l'a parfaitement expliqué il ils
pompent si j'ose dire de l'essence en
russie pour le servir en allemagne donc
il a à la fois un conte il avait un
contrat vis de la russie donc qu'il veut
stopper mais il ya aussi les allemands
qui ont qui est qui compte sur cette
énergie et toute la problématique du
reste il la pose la problématique de ce2
du renouvellement de nos sources
d'énergie en europe le problème n'est
pas si simple et quand la commission
européenne dit dans un an on aura plus
besoin des russes les vrais économistes
qui connaissent bien ce sujet savent que
ça va être très compliqué ackermann sait
puisqu'on est sur la thématique des
les sanctions l'impact des sanctions des
décisions il ya un sommet de l'union
européenne demain
sans doute alourdir les sanctions
économiques contre la russie vous qui
êtes en prise avec la avec la russie et
notamment via vos sources vos contacts
et via les médias russes
l'impact économique il se fait ressentir
à quel point pour la population russe
aujourd'hui ce qui est très important
c'est que le rouble a perdu beaucoup de
sa valeur
à peu près 30% voire plus parce que le
le dollar était ya encore relativement
peu de temps à 70 roubles il attend à
peu près s'enroule et l'euro a été
légèrement dessus et maintenant l'euro
atteint atteint 113 au rouble c'est
quelque chose même après l'annexion de
la crimée le robinet à tomber aussi bas
donc pour les russes bien sûr les
produits quotidien deviennent plus chers
et puis bientôt il y aura aussi un
manque notamment pas tellement de
produits alimentaires je ne pense que la
russie peut assurer sa sécurité
alimentaire peut-être il y aura pas
beaucoup de produits importés mais ils
vont pas mourir de faim en revanche
beaucoup de pièces détachées y compris
pour leur industrie aéronautique ne
seront plus livre est donc peu à peu
avec aussi le départ quand même il ya
des chaînes et des entreprises qui
restent mais il y en a énormément qui
sont partis et est donc bon pour
certains ils vont se débrouiller par
exemple mcdonald's est parti qu'ils
avaient une chaîne de plusieurs
centaines de restaurants entre avec la
russie mais ils vont maintenant
utiliser une chaîne russe qui s'appelle
hong konk lavagna
dia vanilla
et ils ont fait de la lettre m de man de
nice c'est comme si l'on tournait à 90°
et relier l et les laits pied de la
lettre m pour en faire en russe enlevée
mais est ce que la qualité sera
exactement pareil ça on ne sait pas
enterré sans devoir la résine la
résilience la rapidité de réaction quand
même de mes jeux mais je crois que
l'industrie on va souffrir et j'ajoute
quand même que
donc le patron de total de total a versé
des larmes odile ou pas crocodiles on a
entendu qu'il était sur le point de
pleurer mais en réalité objectivement
c'est vrai que toutes les entreprises
étrangères
qui paient quand même les impôts et les
taxes
dans
l'économie russe objectivement participe
bien sûr mais bien sûr safer personne ne
le nie mais bon après la question c'est
qui qui doit prendre la responsabilité
de l'embargo est ce que c'est l'état où
l'entreprise bref il ya une question je
voulais vous posez peut-être que la
réponse n'est pas facile est-ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de russes qui quitte la russie
depuis depuis plusieurs semaines ben oui
oui oui oui je crois que face à ces
c'est un des points intéressants de la
façon dont ces sanctions ont été conçus
parce qu'elle en fait elles frappent
sept classes moyennes supérieures qui
sait on peut dire qu'il ya largement
bénéficié des années poutine bon les
années poutine c'est des années
du point de vue économique où il ya eu
quand même un certain essor et et eux
étaient habitués à pouvoir
à vivre à crédit en fait ils empruntent
très largement les russes parce qu'ils
savent qu'ils peuvent facilement
rembourser parce que les salaires croise
le l'économie croit bon sauf que là
aujourd'hui la banque centrale pour
maîtriser le laos du rouble a été obligé
de monter les taux d'intérêt à 20%
donc comme beaucoup ont des crédits à
taux variables enfin vous voyez donc ces
sept classes moyennes supérieures qui
profitaient enfin qui était dans l'est
des postes voilà deux directions souvent
à moscou dans des grandes villes elle
est frappée de plein fouet et en plus
elle a conscience que ce sera beaucoup
plus difficile d'aller passer des
vacances à l'étranger désormais parce
que c'est ce qui c'est ce qu'ils vont
voilà facilement en egypte ou en turquie
dès qu'il ya un dès qu'ils ont quelques
jours pour prendre un peu le soleil et
voilà et cela se disent tout d'un coup
que leur leur leur avenir s'est assombri
que les perspectives sont son boucher en
fait il se voit revenir un peu à ce
qu'ils ont connu dans les années 80-90 à
l'union soviétique et et c est de ça ils
ne veulent pas quoi qu'on en dise enfin
quoi qu'en dise le pouvoir poutinien qui
quelque part remet au goût du jour enfin
les valeurs soviétique
pour eux c'est non et donc effectivement
il ya beaucoup de départ oui il ya des
gens partout où ils peuvent et dès
qu'ils le peuvent alors beaucoup par la
finlande puisqu'elle plus d'avions ils
prennent le train ils vont à helsinki et
puis de là ils prennent des avions vers
le
nul de ses mais c'est vrai que
on y reviendra sur cette thématique là
je vous redonner la parole aux uns et
aux autres parce que j'aurai qu'on se
concentre de nouveau sur la prise de
parole de vladimir lénine ski avec vous
laetitia parce qu'il ya quand même dont
il est dans un registre qui tranche avec
les prises de parole officielle oui
c'est totalement inédit gaia a
pratiquement fait ma chronique avant moi
parce que parce que vous avez parlé à
gaya de l'émotion et c'est effectivement
l'émotion le registre de l'émotion qui
supporte toute la communication de
wohlen et mears et l'inscrit c'est
frappant dans les exemples qu'il prend
même dans les mots qu'il emploie c'est
toujours un vocabulaire très simple d
idée très concrète parce que bien sûr
vous l'avez compris dans sa tournée des
parlements et s'adresse aux
parlementaires mais s'adresse au peuple
au peuple à nous donc il touche au coeur
directement vous avez utilisé le mot
coeur ça me fait plaisir parce que ils
étaient vraiment tous les buts de ma
chronique c'est le coeur qu'il touche
volume est masquée avec sa communication
et non pas nos têtes voilà ça fait toute
la différence et d'ailleurs dans son
allocution il a commencé dès les
premières minutes avec cet exemple de la
maternité de mario paul bombarder
écoutez le et ils ont commencé à tuer
les les gens dans cette maternité
sur lesquels le russe ont lancé les
bombes il avait des gens il y avait des
femmes qui se préparer à accoucher et la
plupart d'entre eux
ont survécu mais certaines ont été
gravement blessées et une femme a dû
amputer son pied qui était fracturée et
une autre femme avait en bassin fracturé
et son bébé est mort avant la naissance
la femme on a on essayait de sauver la
femme
elles demandaient les médecins de
laisser mourir de ne pas l'aider
elle n'avait pas de réelle ne voyez pas
des raisons pour vivre
elle est morte
voilà c'est typique de la rhétorique de
zellers crise et des exemples très
concrets c'est cette violence verbaliser
décrite pour encore une fois éveiller
les consciences européenne il sait
pertinemment que les télés françaises
ont tourné en boucle plus de 48 heures
sur ce bombardement de marioupol ça a
ouvert toutes les éditions pendant plus
de deux jours thomas il sait très bien
que le peuple français est très émue que
le peuple français accueille en ce
moment même les ukrainiens et donc il
sait utiliser
voilà ce registre de l'émotion utilisez
des cas comme ça qu'ils vont nous
toucher directement et qui vont
peut-être faire réagir les populations
et puis vous l'avez dit aussi dans sa
tournée européenne
il rappelle l'histoire de chaque pays à
chaque fois pour nous c'était verdun
vous l'avez dit devant westminster
c'était churchill et shakespeare il a
dit il a dit la cuisse la question pour
nous est d'être ou de ne pas être devant
le congrès américain c'était pearl
harbor et le 11 septembre et puis les
allemands l'holocauste et puis devant
les six raëlien 7 ce parallèle n'a pas
vraiment plu à une majorité d'israéliens
et l'a fait un parallèle entre la shoah
et la guerre de poutine mais ce qui
marque surtout dans la communication de
célas qui sait sa sincérité et son
authenticité
parce que ce sont deux objectifs être
sincère et authentique que vise tous les
dirigeants et que très peu réussissent à
atteindre est-ce que vous avez été ému
monsieur par exemple sur le sénateur oui
moi j'ai été ému par et j'étais tout est
enfin oui j'étais bien sûr ému par
l'instant par les paroles prononcées par
les exemples ont été évoqués et moi je
veux mettre en relation ça et le langage
de poutine qui lui d'une vulgarité d'une
violence effroyable et a parlé hier ou
avant-hier je l'entendais parler
d'ukrainiens comme des moucherons qu'on
aurait dans la bouche et qu'il convient
de recracher je veux dire ce sont des
termes qui faut même aller les chercher
pour pouvoir voir et les inventer
d'adolphe hitler tout à fait tout à fait
face est vraiment ils sont considérés
comme des sous-hommes alors quand on
veut en fait enfin l'histoire de
l'ukraine et la russie montrent que ce
ya pas peut-être peuple plus frère et
dans les origines et dans l'histoire que
que ces deux pays et je trouve que le
contraste est d'une violence absolue et
ça ne va franchement pas dans le sens
que poutine de mon point de vue gagner à
kerman sais c'est aussi une guerre
d'image 7 cette guerre d'image et de
communication il ya jean yves le drian
notre mise affaires étrangères qui
disait poutine a perdu la bataille de la
communication bon ça change rien pour
les habitants de marioupol dans la ville
est presque totalement détruite un
d'entendre ça mais si on prend un peu de
recul dans l'analyse c'est vrai que
c'est aussi une bataille d'image et une
guerre d'image et de communication oui
et poutine a essayé peut-être de pallier
à ce gain de 2,2 et lenski par rapport à
lui parce que c'est vrai que c'est ce
qui est quelqu'un de sincère sympathie
que vous avez union patine naturelle
vous n'avez aucune empathie avec poutine
quand il a fait tous ces discours le 21
février quand il a annoncé en fait son
programme n 24 quand il a déclaré la
guerre et ensuite à quelques autres
reprises et c'est toujours une sorte de
haine froide chi chi le pénètre et qui
se fait sentir mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que poutine a donc essayé de
pallier à cela en organisant des grandes
célébrations le 18 mars à l'occasion de
la de huitième anniversaire de
l'annexion de la crimée en faisant des
grandes festivités en organisant de
grandes festivités partout dans le pays
et donc là il est apparu devant le
peuple le col roulé dans un grand stade
c'est ça la junte avait deux cent mille
personnes et encore des dizaines de
milliers qui étaient autour mais c'était
toujours cette même haine froide d'une
part et d'autre part j'ai trouvé que
c'était d'une indécence absolue parce
que c'était une fête avec des discours
de grand propagandiste du régime de
quelques réalisateurs metteurs en scène
acteur la porte parole du ministère des
affaires étrangères maria zakharova une
autre grand propagandiste qui est la
chef de rta château d un margherita
simonian et il faut dire que cette ce
spectacle d'une sorte de kermesse où le
public a été totalement transporté qui
chantait à l'unisson avec les chanteurs
d'aider des chants patriotiques et au il
y avait quelque chose de totalement
indécent en cela et donc je pense que
peut-être pour son peuple qui ne sait
pas exactement ce qui se passe parce que
les sources de l'information est établi
que savent les russes et que ça allait
mais mais mais en tout cas il y avait
donc cette célébration cette jubilation
ce désir d'aller jusqu'au bout et
détruire le cren et quand vous voyez
cela et vous avez en tête les images
d'un mario paul qui est réellement une
ville martyre et ou encore reste dans
des conditions totalement indescriptible
cent mille personnes vous savez et on ne
gagne pas la bataille de communication
comme ça bien sûr je propose un conte à
un calme et de nous rejoindre pour
rester sur le l'impact en quelque sorte
on parlait beaucoup d'émotion grâce à à
laetitia de ceux de ce discours françois
cantin du président ukrainien comment
les les sénateurs ont ils vécu ce moment
mais c'est vrai que c'était une séance
solennelle 1 on n'a personne vol de
vivre un peu un moment historique au
parlement cet après midi ne serait ce
que parce que c'était inédit est cette
déclaration par visio par zoom comme
cela d'un chef d'état en guerre en
simultané dans les deux chambres du
parlement
effectivement on a au vu ces sénateurs
qui sont revenus malgré la suspension
des travaux pour siéger ils nous ont
parlé effectivement d'émotion écouté par
exemple guillaume gontard le chef de
file des écologistes au sénat est
également claude malhuret pour les
indépendants un groupe de la droite
macron compatible
effectivement un moment historique qu'un
président d'une démocratie le président
de l'ukraine s'adresse au parlement au
parlement français dans la situation
actuelle une des chromos cratie qui est
attaqué par un dictateur évidemment
c'est un moment de très grande émotion
de voir en direct sur sept sur sept
grands ce grand écran le président
ukrainien un moment d'émotion partagée
par tous debout applaudissant aussi bien
à l'assemblée nationale qu'au sénat
c'est la première chose qu'on retient de
cette qu'on retiendra de de cet
après-midi alors autre chose que
retiennent les sénateurs c'est cette
référence à la devise française
notamment ce qu'il est dit la france est
bien doit mettre va mettre fin à cette
guerre contre la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité disant également qu'il
attendait de la france de notre
leadership je cite que nous aidions à
restaurer l'intégrité territoriale de
l'ukraine tout le débat maintenant et on
l'a eu à notre micro cet après midi
c'est de savoir où placer le curseur
notamment sur le volet militaire écoutez
à ce propos pierre laurent pour les
communistes et bruno retailleau chef de
file des as l'air au sénat savons depuis
le début que la création d'une no fly
zone qui signifierait la possibilité
pour un avion de l'otan une armée de
l'otan d'abattre un navire e
signifierait l'entrée en guerre de
l'otan donc nous ne sommes pas
favorables à cette entrée longueur en
soutien des valeurs ses valeurs de
liberté de souveraineté pour un peuple
et l'unité d'un peuple
pour nous qui vont infliger des
sanctions on va avoir un effet boomerang
on l'a déjà sur l'inflation mais que
c'est une autre forme de guerre et qu'on
doit il prendre notre part et toute
notre part dernier point thomas et vous
l'avez déjà évoqué sur ce plateau cela
concerne ces entreprises un qualifié de
machine de guerre russe et le président
ukrainien de sites et laura merling
auchan ou encore renault il les appelle
ces entreprises a quitté le marché russe
ces entreprises doivent arrêter de
financer le meurtre d'enfants et de
femmes et le viol on a entendu les
sénateurs très prudent notamment à
droite il hésita à critiquer ces
entreprises pour eux la priorité ainsi
vient d'augmenter les sanctions sur la
russie est d'organiser l'accueil des
réfugiés thomas merci quand l'un pour
pour ce voilà ce ces détails des
réactions des sénateurs après le
discours de développement zelensky alain
guillemoles qu'est ce qu'on peut
attendre de ce sommet européen demain
puisque on reste sur cette idée de 2 de
sanctions économiques de pression
économique mise sur la russie alors
c'est vrai que beaucoup de choses ont
déjà été faites mais que en fait toucher
là vraiment la russie c'est s'attaquer à
l'énergie un sas et enfin voilà on
tourne autour de ça depuis depuis tout à
l'heure donc
on a vu que quand même que total a fait
un pas en annonçant hier déjà que qu'ils
allaient mettre fin les contrats d'achat
de pétrole d'ici la fin de l'année 2022
il reste dans le dans les achats de gaz
et dans l'exploitation puisqu'en fait
ils sont aussi engagés avec des
partenaires russes dans l'exploitation
de gisements gaziers
mais enfin si une décision politique
devait intervenir
de mettre fin c'est à ces contrats
est-ce que la responsabilité de total
serait la même ou bien total pourrait-il
invoqué comme le font d'autres
entreprises quand quant à une décision
politique n'est ce pas
elle s'applique est donc totale pourrait
du coup se dire bon voilà je peux me
retirer du marché russe sans avoir à
payer de pénalités donc c'est peut-être
ça qui sera choisi bon on évoque aussi
peut-être des sanctions diplomatiques
avec la réduction de personnel dans les
ambassades et puis la liste des
personnalités touché parce que les
sanctions touchent tout le monde touche
tous les russes alors il s'agit aussi
d'envoyer un message aux russes de leurs
10 ans bon on on vous sanctionne mais on
vise surtout ceux qui ont les moyens
d'éviter de pâtir le plus des sanctions
qui sont prises une des sanctions
sectorielle donc on ajoute des noms à la
liste de ceux qui sont qui soutiennent
le régime et qui donc qui sont quelque
part complice de cette guerre et puis en
même temps on ne peut être les moyens de
de l'influencé le pouvoir russe donc on
peut s'attendre à ce que la liste
s'allonge la liste des oligarques parce
qu'on touche pas un peu les limites de
ces sanctions économiques aujourd'hui
d'abord je voudrais quand même faire
observer une chose c'est que si on se
réfère au vote qui est intervenu à
l'assemblée des nations unies si on
additionne l'ensemble des pays qui n'ont
pas voté les sanctions on arrive à
environ 5 milliards d'habitants donc je
pense qu'il faut bien intégrer cette
dimension si vous additionnez la chine
sur combien l'inde sur 6 milliards et
demi si vous additionnez la chine l'inde
nombre de pays d'afrique l'afrique du
sud a certes aux deux pays nombre de
pays d'amérique latine on a fait un
calcul qui est tout à fait étonnant et
il faut pas imaginer que contrairement à
ce qu'on a tendance à war nous ici en
europe le monde entier et est
entièrement tourné donc ça veut dire que
l'économie russe elle seule elle se
tourne et hervé vilard
une âme il paie et
j'allais dire une résilience que l'on
connaît bien chez eux et donc
immédiatement les négociations entre la
chine et la russie pour la fourniture de
plus grandes quantités de gaz a déjà
commencé donc je dire sont des pays qui
sont moins sujets à la bureaucratie que
nos pays européens et qui peuvent assez
rapidement se mettre en on sait très
bien que les sanctions que nous les
européens nous avons pris notamment dans
le domaine agricole et qui ont vraiment
durement touché les agriculteurs
français la filière porcine à filière
volaille la pomme etc et bien
immédiatement en russie même défi lire
se sont créés et j'allais presque dire
instantanément vous citiez tout faire
l'exemple tout à fait incroyable de ces
burger king qui devient un oncle vania
il faut pas et ce que je veux simplement
des il faut pas imaginer que tous les
pays du monde seront mis la russie ou au
banc et ce sera quelque part dans les
logiciels futur et à essayer d'intégrer
à pays comme l'inde est étrangement
silencieux le premier ministre japonais
a été voir le premier les indiens pour
lire il faut prendre des sanctions et il
n'a pas eu vraiment de réponses vont
intégrer cette dimension qui rachète le
pétrole au risque a baissé sur le marché
dont à l'europe ne veut pas lui il ya
aussi c'est aussi ces enjeux économiques
qui qui profite à certains elle vous
posez la question de 2,2 des limites on
va dire de l'impact des sanctions
économiques effectivement votre réponse
elle est édifiante et derrière ça il ya
jusqu'où va dans les livraisons d'armes
par exemple on a appris il ya quelques
minutes en cette fin d'après midi que la
suède annonce par exemple l'envoi de
5000 armes anti-char supplément cette
terre à l'ukraine bon ça répond d'une
certaine façon à une demande que
volodymyr dns qui faisait devant le
parlement français il nous a réclamé des
armes on écoute nous avons besoin d'eux
dad encore plus date plus de soutien
pour que la liberté ne parle pas elle
doit être bien armé les chars les armes
antichars les avions de combat la
défense est rien vous pouvez nous était
nous en avons besoin vous pouvez pour
que la liberté ne tarde pas le monde de
douala soutenir
christian caumont je vais pas vous
demander de dire quelles armes mon livre
parce que voilà il ya quelques notions
de secret à respecter mais sur le
principe
jusqu'où on peut aller là aussi c'est un
peu la même question sur les sanctions
jusqu'où on peut aller avec le risque
inhérent de
provocation je mets des guillemets en
tout cas que ce soit perçu comme une
provocation par l'onu a déjà le système
qui a été arrêté par l'europe car c'est
l'europe qui globalement est
collectivement arrêté le 10 poésie le
système doit être bien identifiés à
savoir qu' il n'y a aucun soldat aux
européens qu'ils pénètrent en ukraine
pour aller livrer des armes ces armes
sont livrés dans les pays voisins
singulièrement la pologne et d'autres
aussi dans des sortes de hub ou
l'ensemble des pays européens qui
apporte des armes les déposent et après
elles sont réparties par les ukrainiens
qui viennent les chercher et qui les
transporte et qui les transportent de
manière la plus confidentielle c'est
pour ça que en plus je pense qu'il n'est
pas très utile de trop communiquer si
vous voulez sur la quantité et la
qualité des armes parce que il ya des
gens qui sûrement mal intentionnées
pourraient identifier et neutraliser ce
genre de convois les armes que l'on
fournit à partir du moment où le temps a
dit clairement qu'il n'était pas
question d'investir l'espace aérien donc
pas de on ne fournit pas d'avion bon
maintenant on voit que les russes
utilisent beaucoup les blindés
ce n'est pas un secret d'état de dire
que les armes anti-char vous venez
d'évoquer ce que va faire la suède bon
c'est plutôt ce sens ça d'autant que
maintenant les armes anti-char sont des
armes à la fois peu importants tant en
poids facilement maniable facilement
utilisable et qui font des dégâts
considérables à
une mine en pas une mine est une arme
antichar contraintes et 72 le char est
terminée c'est fini et on peut même les
utiliser à courte distance sur des
navires qui vont approcher odessa donc
c'est ce sont des armes qui sont très
utiles c'est pas fatalement l'importance
et la qualité du matériel c'est d'abord
son nombre car ils ont vraiment besoin
de leur stock soit renouvelée et d'autre
part la maniabilité c'est d'ailleurs la
silla facile à utiliser et facile à
utiliser il et il a compris
qu'est ce qu'on sait de de l'état de
l'armée russe parce qu'il ya là aussi
c'est très difficile d'avoir des
informations est ce que l est en train
de s'embourber en ukraine est ce que
effectivement j'ai lu ça hier il ya dans
certaines zones l'armée ukrainienne car
repris du terrain qu'est ce qu'on qu'est
ce qu'on en sait ou alors c'est sûr que
fin on dit toujours la première victime
de la guerre c'est la vérité oui c'est
un dicton de journalistes c'est vrai que
c'est très difficile enfin on a des
estimations qui sont diamétralement
opposées
mais enfin on a quand même
ce qui existait pas par le passé on a on
a un certain nombre de gens qui font ce
qu'on appelle de de l'intelligence en
source ouverte c'est-à-dire des gens qui
sur internet regarde toutes les vidéos
les localisent identifie et donc voilà
donc c'est un peu une source
indépendante
donc une communauté de chercheurs
bénévoles comme ça qu'ils communiquent
ensemble sur notamment sur twitter et
donc ces gens là font la liste de
l'ensemble des chars qui ont été
atteints par ces fameux missiles anti
chars qui ont l'air quand même de bien
fonctionner et donc on arrive quand même
à
corroborer grâce à ça les chiffres qui
sont donnés par les uns et les autres et
donc
bon alors ces chercheurs nous disent il
ya autour de 1500 véhicules
blindés et autres russes qui auraient
été atteints si on compte le nombre
fallait les équipages qui étaient à
l'intérieur et c'est donc on arrive
quand même à des chiffres assez
considérable est ce que ces
10000 comme le dit le pentagone est ce
que c'est quinze mille comme le dit
l'armée ukrainienne
morts parmi les russes en tout cas même
même si on prend une estimation basse
ils ont de 7,8 milles c'est quand même
considérable puisqu'on fait toujours
cette comparaison avec la guerre
d'afghanistan 1 où les rues sont ont
perduré les soviétiques à l'époque bien
sûr il s'agissait pas des russes ont
perdu
quinze mille soldats en 15 ans quoi donc
donc la voile
[Musique]
non moi voilà donc en tout cas mais
alors bon la difficulté étant que la
russie cache ses victimes puisque
l'armée ukrainienne ne cesse de dire que
les russes ne veulent pas ramasser les
morts etc enfin vous voyez c'est avec
avec une parade qui était voilà mais
c'est la guerre la guerre et salah qui a
été trouvé par les ukrainiens ça a été
annoncé aujourd'hui kiev annonce
utiliser la reconnaissance faciale pour
identifier les soldats russes tués il
est ensuite signalé leur mort par un
système d'appel automatique il pas aussi
une intelligence artificielle entre en
jeu pour ensuite signalé leur mort à
leurs proches à leur famille en russie
comme voilà en envoyant la photo du
soldat reconnaissance faciale
identification du nom du soldat
identification des proches ils trouvent
le soin leur numéro de téléphone ou
alors un réseau social et il envoie
voilà c'est l'usagé l'intérieur ben je
ne fais que répéter ce que kiev a
annoncé aujourd'hui mais voilà les armes
qu'on utilise pour justement et j'en
reviens à la question qu'on avait évoqué
tout à l'heure et akerman sur la ce que
les russes savent de cette guerre quoi
écouter les russes malheureusement ne
savent pas grand chose parce que déjà il
est interdit d'appeler
cette opération spéciale la guerre c'est
considéré pratiquement comme un grave
délit par an de prison il est interdit
de dire la vérité sur les pertes sur la
souffrance des civils et ses trains on
est toutes site accusée de calomnie est
donc là aussi ça peut être procès
jugement des années de prison et ses
trains ce que les russes montre et
martèle sans arrêt c'est que c'est une
opération est destinée à soutenir
les 1 2 les vingt deux ans dentiste du
donbass et neutraliser l'infrastructure
militaire ukrainienne il martèle sans
arrêt qu'il ne bombarde pas les
bâtiments d'habitation
ils ne tuent pas les civils et donc les
images par exemple de mario paul
totalement détruit et qui nous il y
avait quand même quatre cent mille
habitants ou de quartier qui est
deuxième ville d'ukraine où il ya à
l'heure qu'il est près d'un millier
d'immeubles d'habitation détruits dont
50 écoles et ou plus 50 écoles tout ça
les russes ne l'ont pas c'est totalement
nier et je veux l'une des grandes
propagandistes madame simonian qui est
la patronne des artères à château des
dents dans une émission avec le devenir
soloviov qui est le 2 l'inde est aussi
des plus grand propagandiste donc il
sait il faut un peu la compétition qui
dira des choses plus affreuse que
l'autre et elle a dit littéralement ceux
ci nous n'appelons ce passe à une guerre
parce que la guerre c'est beaucoup plus
cruelle notre armée préserve les civils
et je vous le dis en tant que chrétienne
croyante que si notre armée réellement
bombardé des bâtiments civils et tuer
les civils je ne serais pas venu chez
vous parlez à l'antenne ma conscience me
leur est interdit mais
les téléphones sont complètement coupées
parce que il me semble quand même
difficile d'imaginer qu'on n'a pas la
moindre information accès aux réseaux
sociaux
certains c'est interdire oui espérons le
merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je rappelle alain guilbaud le
titre de votre livre ukraine le réveil
d'une nation c'est publié aux éditions
les petits matins merci encore